thanks for coming and thanks organizers
for inviting me to this great workshop
I'm going to talk about learning mixer
self gaussians again but this time we
will learn mixture of general captions
assistance based on joint work with
syncing of home and sham cackling so
also a sham already introduced learning
mixture of gaussians problem just a nice
story here that I want to tell so
there's a story about cramps so in late
nineteenth century the largest Weldon he
caught a lot crabs and he for each of
the crab he measured his forehead or
body length ratio for a lot of crabs and
then it turns out this ratio is
distributed like this distribution so
well didn't saw this distribution and he
thought this is not normal it's normally
it should look like a Gaussian
distribution so this of course is
nothing like a Gaussian distribution so
he went to a person for help and the
ideas they had is well maybe this means
that this whatever a thousand crabs they
he caught it's not just one kind of crab
it might be two different species of
crabs each each kind of crab will have
if you can distinguish them each kind of
crab
if you measure this free show it will be
distributed like a Gaussian distribution
but because these two kinds of crabs are
mixed together when you plot the density
function of this ratio it becomes a
mixture of two Gaussian distributions so
the density function will just be the
sum of two Gaussian some of the density
functions of two Gaussian distributions
so now the problem becomes I already
knows this density function so
Oh does this give me enough the
information for me to tell what should
be the parameters for the two Gaussian
distributions if I can separate them so
what are the means variances and mixing
weights for these two Gaussian
distributions that when you take the sum
off their density functions they look
like that and person had a very nice
algorithm for solving zzz's it's based
on the method of moments so you compute
the first six moments moments are just
expectations of polynomials first moment
is just the mean second moment is
variance and so on so after you compute
all these six moments it gives you a lot
of equations on the parameters on some
unknown parameters that means variances
and so on and then somehow he can solve
the set of equations and get the correct
parameters so indeed this distribution
is the sum of these two Gaussian
distributions and this this kind of
algorithm is later known as semester of
moments and it has become really popular
in statistics so more concretely
learning weeks for a forgotten problem
you are given samples from one of one
one knot of cake options in the previous
case it was in one dimensional but that
doesn't have to be it could be in some
high dimensional space say n dimensional
the goal is to find the mean and the
variance and mixing weights for all
these different Gaussian distributions
just by observing the samples here's
another example that's in two dimensions
you get these points and maybe they come
from as a mixture of these two Gaussian
distributions
so essentially persons algorithm or
persons argument shows that we can solve
this problem when the dimension is one
and the number of gaussians is two and
we can do this just by estimating the
first six moments and solve a set of
polynomial equations later
this result is generalized by Mara and
valance they show that the same idea can
actually be used to solve to learn a
mixture of gaussians for arbitrary
number of conscience and upper tray
number of dimensions and instead of the
first six moments they use the first
order K moments and K is the number of
cautions we want to learn so this is
very nice but there's a problem here so
it uses order K moments but we are not
even these moments directly we are given
these samples so we we need to estimate
the moments from the samples and it
turns out in order to estimate all these
moments accurately enough for the
algorithm we will need a number of
samples we need will be exponential in
the number of gaussian components and
also their algorithm also runs in times
as exponential in this parameter so this
is not very good if this number of
Gaussian component it's too large
say if they are ten different kinds of
crops that we cannot distinguish then if
we want to distinguish them using this
algorithm maybe we need to catch all of
the crabs in the world and we still
don't have enough
so perhaps are not so happy about that
but how can we solve this problem about
let's look at a crab story again it's
usually told in two ways that I just
don't I told you but in fact well then
of course didn't just randomly came up
with features at the forehead over body
length ratio and it doesn't make sense
right is that he you made many more
measurements he measured maybe all these
lenses and all the ratios between these
lens so what this gives you is give you
a mixture of Gaussian in much higher
dimensions well by the way the reason
that they only looked at that particular
statistics is because that's the only
statics that looks significantly
different from a Gaussian distribution
but of course even you can still be a
mixture of two gaussians maybe there are
very close lexis then you still look
like a Gaussian but in fact that's not
that's not true and maybe there are
useful information in all these other
dimensions says they didn't use so why
why do I think that having a mixture of
gaussians in higher dimensions should
help us well because usually higher
dimension things are harder to compute
but in this case higher dimensions gives
us much more information in particular
if we use the method of moments because
if we use messed up moments if we are in
one dimensional then first ka moments
just give you K numbers but you've
higher we are in high dimensional say
then the force moment for example is
defined to be the expectation of all
these correlations between different
coordinates each coordinate
xi1 xi2 xin x i for this I 1 I 2 I 3 I 4
can be chosen from 1 to N and recall we
are in a dimensional space
so this force older woman really forms a
symmetric force order tensor so when we
have say 20 dimensions the force moment
tensor has more than 4,000 this change
parameters it's really 23 was 4 so but
on the other hand in 20 Dimensions every
gaussian component will have only 231
parameters this includes the parameters
for the mean for the correct matrix and
for one extra parameter for the mixing
weight so now you see all these
parameters should give us some
polynomial equation over these unknown
parameters so so naively we have more
than 4,000 equations we have to 131
times whatever number of cautions that
that's the number of unknowns so in the
best case we should be able to hope to
learn 20 gaussians using just the first
order moment and of course when n grows
if this number will grow as n 2z for
this number Abel only grow as n squared
so so we can even hope to learn even
more cautions well of course this is
just a heuristic argument we cannot
really solve system of polynomial
equations also these equations might be
redundant but luckily in some special
case indeed in the algorithms that Tom
just talked about we can make use of
this high dimensional structure and
indeed it makes learning mixture of
gaussians easier so these are a series
of words on learning experience so the
first one is what Tom just talked about
us work with Stan you so they can learn
mixture of case verifications using just
second and third moments and there are
algorithm works whenever the means are
linearly independent but in order for
this canoe
to be satisfiable we need a number of
dimensions to be larger than the number
of components so later there are some
follow-up works that improve this result
so basically so there's one works that
are Rendon is going to talk about this
afternoon what they show is you can
learn mixture of K Cowan's using
constant number of moments when the
dimension is larger than K to some
epsilon where epsilon is also a constant
it can be a really small constant but
the number of moments you need would
depend on epsilon and there are
algorithm works when the means are
perturb which I will make more precise
later for now just think when the means
are in general position there are other
related works that are really very
similar to this work they give a similar
guarantees and trade-offs but
unfortunately all these works still will
only work for spherical currents matrix
or maybe some other highly structured
covariance matrices if the current
matrix can be quite general it does not
work and for example in the crab case
the spherical currents matrix really
correspond to the assumptions that all
these different ratios or lens or
whatever statistics we measured they are
have to be independent which is not very
reasonable in many settings so in this
talk we'll really try to learn a mixture
of Keg options in polynomial time and
even if they have generals non-spherical
coverage matrices but we cannot hope to
do this in the worst case as mo Chou and
Bannon showed this is impossible and if
you just use a polynomial in K number of
samples so instead of the worst case we
hope to work in this smooth analysis
setting which is measured in stock so
smooth analysis is first proposed by
Spoonman
ten it's used to analyze simplex
algorithm for linear programming but
it's also very reasonable for many of
the learning settings actually so in
this case instances of the algorithm do
not get worse case instances instead the
instances are perturb locally before the
argument to the algorithm so it's like a
sophist and adversary can choose an
arbitrary worst case instance but before
giving this instance to the algorithm
some either nature or some some good guy
will perturb the instance locally at
random and then this perturb instance is
given to the algorithm so the underlying
idea is maybe the we are trying to learn
these true parameters that arise in
nature these two parameters
maybe we shouldn't think about them as a
fixed number because these numbers are
themselves noisy maybe this whatever
ratio of the crab depend on the climate
of the year and if you do it in
different years they are slightly
different right so the true parameters
you should really think about it as
something that's locally perturbed
around a fixed value and alcala McBee if
you have this perturbation it helps a
lot by avoiding degenerate cases if I
have a bunch of points in a high
dimensional space and I perturb them
then there will be no three points on a
line for example so in the mixture of
gaussian case this correspond to our
adversary will first choose a mixture of
gaussians so basically the parameter is
the means variance and amazing weights
and then these parameters are perturbed
and then the samples are generated
according to the perturb parameters the
algorithm sees these samples and go off
the algorithm is really to learn the
perturb parameters
usually you know mathematically if you
have a problem something singular if you
take you through to question you must
have it also in numerical method that
you still have problems well so so
smooth analysis setting I I think in
some sense tries to say that will not be
the case for this particular problem for
example if you have an arbitrary matrix
of course it can be a low rank right if
you try to do a inverse it doesn't work
but if you randomly perturb it it will
be for rank but of course as you said
there could still be a problem that also
it's for rank it might have really bad
condition number which will make your
life harder again right but in this case
for example for matrices we know if you
do a random perturbation at least for
some random perturbations the smallest
singular value of the matrix will be
bounded so the condition number of the
matrix will with high probability not be
so bad and that is the case when you
after you do is the perturbation it
makes things reasonable yeah so so
here's a picture to illustrate the idea
of so for a general problem even if it's
hard it might have some easy instances
but the distribution of easy and hard
instances can be quite arbitrary it
could look like that but if I have an
algorithm that works in the smooth
analysis setting then this really cannot
be the case because for example if I'm
here and I am perturbed locally I I'm
still in the heart region I I cannot
solve my problem so if I have an
algorithm that works in this motion
analysis setting it really means the
problem should look like this most
instances are easy there are some hard
instances but in any small local
neighborhood most of the instances are
still easy
and in this talk we will work in this
motion analysis framework we will assume
the interest in the mean and currents
matrices are randomly perturb by some
Gaussian noise so in this model our it
salts show that given samples from this
smooth mixture of k gaussians
in the first case we assume all these
captions have zero mean so zero means
are 0 and not perturb so in this case if
the number of dimensions is much larger
than 100 k square K is the number of
Gaussian components in then we can learn
all these parameters in polynomial time
and polynomial number of samples and all
of those are with high probability over
their perturbations that we do in this
motion analysis setting you means the
perturbations of variance of the
perturbation yes so row we should think
about as a parameter that can be any
universe polynomial in all the other
parameters so as a running time of our
algorithm and sample complexity will
depend on polynomially in 1 over Rho
yeah so the algorithm succeeds with high
probability over the perturbation and
also over the sampling procedure
afterwards
similarly we can generalize this result
by instead of the 0 mean Gaussian so we
can learn general Gaussian so you can
have arbitrary mean and covariance
matrices as long as they are perturbed
still the guarantee is very similar row
is interpolating between worst case
incomplete
yes right yeah if Joe is really large
then it's like a completely random place
and if Rho is 0 its worst case
and so our algorithm is also based on
method of moments in fact our algorithm
we will use third fourth and sixth
moments so only constant order of
moments and in this talk I'm really
going to just focus on this first result
theorem in case and in some sense you
should not think about this as a very
simple special case of the general
problem this is actually one of the
harder cases there are these algorithms
that work for learning mixture of
gaussians when the means are separated
but in this case of course they are all
the same and also since we are using
method of moments if the if the
gaussians all have zero mean then the
third order moment it's just all zeros
in general all the odds moment are all
zeros so we don't get any information
from those so how do we learn a mixture
of zero mean Gaussian well here's an
outline which shouldn't make sense now
so let's remove these steps I will go
step by step back from the solution and
see why do we need all these steps and
how do we do all those steps so so
what's the main difficulty in this case
and or what is the approach that we are
trying to take well we know how to learn
mixture of three options that's what
Shaam just talked about basically it's
that algorithm reduces to solve this
kind of first system so if we know
something that's the sum of lambda IVI
when I transpose so that's a matrix we
know something else that's lambda IVI
tensor VI 3 times so this was the second
and third moment for not for the
Gaussian but for the topic model for the
Gaussian you do something else to make
them into this form so we know how to
solve this problem to get the lambda i's
and V eyes if the V eyes are linearly
independent
so we want to apply the same thing to
the mixture of general gaussians problem
so again we will think of this lambda
i's as the mixing weights and these pis
we don't have means anymore
so these VI is think of them as the
vectorized version of the covariance
matrix so if we can get something like
that
we'll be able to apply as a tensor
decomposition algorithm so now of course
the current matrix needs in second order
so this is a product of second order
terms so it should live in the fourth
order moment so let's try we would hope
that the first order moment of the
tensor look like this so basically if
you write this this guy as the matrix
with I 1 I 2 on one set of coordinates
and I 3 I 4 on the other side this is 3d
a low rank matrix that's equal to the WJ
x vectorized version of sigma x a
vectorized version of sigma transpose so
it's very so this guy is very similar to
this kind so if we know this and we know
the same thing for the six solder moment
then we will be done we can directly
apply this algorithm but then the
problem is is this true is this equation
true but you look at the equation for a
while you would realize that this cannot
be true as is this 3d which is for
thinking because this left left hand
side is released a metric right I can
permute I 1 I 2 I 3 I 4 no matter how I
promote it's the same number this
right-hand side is not as symmetric if I
say swap I 2 and I 3 I will get a
different number so these two cannot be
the same so in fact we can of course
computer expectation of this fourth
order moment for adoptions this is known
as assorted serum
by easily swim we can compute it and it
looks like this so it's 3do symmetrized
version four it says I have all the
different choices for breaking these
four indices into two cells so instead
of just this one number we now have two
extra terms and there's not the same as
that one so later in the talk I will
called these guys the unfolded moments
and this guy m4 will be called afforded
moments because it has more symmetry if
we have the unfolded moments the
first-order unfolded moments and the six
other unfolded moments then we can just
apply this tensor decomposition
algorithm directly and we will be done
but unfortunately what we observe are
only these folded moments so we need
some way to get these unfolded moments
only by observing the folded moments and
by the way throughout the talk are also
red letters or the red things will be
unknowns and also blue things will be
things that we already know so the
problem becomes how do we get unfolded
moments because once we get them we can
do a tensor decomposition and we get the
solution we want so there's a very
natural idea to how to get for the
moments also it doesn't work it la la
straights our ideas so here so this
unfolded now it's a sorry it's this
ayaats this unfolded moment x4 if you
considered it has roughly n to the 4
over 8 different entries these we can
treat them as unknowns by observing this
folded moment m4 it gives roughly n to
the 4 over 24 linear equations so this
is really an plus rate was for but it's
roughly done so obviously we don't have
enough number of equations
so we need some more structure on this
unfolded moment x4 but what structure do
we have the most natural structure we
have is that x4 is a low rank matrix
it's the sum of K Rank 1 components as a
rank 1 components are just currents
matrix x transpose so then it's a
problem we want to solve looks like we
have a unknown low rank matrix we get
are all these linear equations or linear
observations on the slow rank matrix
then we want to recover its low rank
matrix so this is cotton matrix sensing
problem is a well studied problem and
there are many nice results for example
this result of been wrecked and faso and
pablo here they show that when linear
equations satisfies a matrix r.i.p
property then we can uniquely determine
this low rank matrix X for given this
observation M for then the problem
becomes does our observation in your
observation satisfy this matrix rmp
property unfortunately the answer is no
this is not satisfied in our case we
chose your exist two mixtures of
captions with very different unfolded
moments but they give the same M for so
this property cannot hold hours many
other properties in the literature but
none of them works in this most analysis
setting if they don't work for some
particular point even if your procured
them you cannot you cannot hope the
properties to be suddenly satisfied
so we need to use some other ways to get
the unfolded moments what the idea is
still because it's a low rank matrix we
can use this low rank property to reduce
the number of variables basically if we
know the span of the currents matrices
so this should really think about the
span of the vector ization of this
covariance matrix is in M plus 1 choose
two dimensional space and u itself has
dimension K so if when you have a matrix
sets and plus 1 choose 2 by K that is
the span of all these course matrices
then we can really write this X 4 matrix
as u times some Whitewater times u
transpose where Y 4 is now only K by K
matrix
and if we know you then just this is a
nonlinear transformation between Y 4 and
X 4 when you take the span you've taken
some canonical vectorization of the
grain yes you take a canonical
vectorization you can find a vector
ization you're like so we know that M 4
gives n 24 over 24 linear equations on
these variables X for all these can be
translated into linear equations on y 4
because y 4 and X 4 are linearly related
so we still have entity for over 24
equations but now why for how many
variables does it have it only has like
K square over 2 variables so the number
of equations is now much larger than the
number of variables so we can hope that
once we solve this linear system it will
give us a unique solution because we
have many more equations since the
number of variables but of course this
is not in general true we need to show
that the coefficient of this linear
system should be a matrix that is not
just for rank but robust be for rank in
the sense that it has a large smallest
singular value therefore whenever you do
the universe is a very stable operation
we can indeed chosen as and the proof
depends heavily on the perturbations
that we have in the smooth down analysis
setting without support perturbation
this is not even true so in this way we
can get matrix X 4 and similarly we can
also reduce the number of variables in X
6 using the same idea and we can find X
6 using a system
although the problem becomes how do we
find the span of the currents matrices
unless we know that we know how to
proceed yes oh well it does not directly
connect you for being a it's also using
the structure of some moments but in a
different way it's very specialized to
the mixture of gaussians
I think yeah so how do we find the span
of their currents matrices so so the
idea we have is maybe even we can look
at the slices of these moments so let's
look at a two-dimensional slice of the
force moment tensor m4 so here I'm using
some MATLAB notation so this just means
I J's sub matrix of this fourth order
tensor m4 so these two injuries are left
so this this sub matrix is a
two-dimensional slice you can compute
again by using either a serum now please
just believe me that if you compute it
it will look like that and now let's
take a closer look so so what is this
matrix this matrix the first term is
actually very nice right as a number
it's a sigma IJ that's a number times
this Sigma matrix so it's so if there
are no other terms only this term then
this matrix will be in the span of the
covariance matrices and as that is what
we want well unfortunately we also have
these other terms but these other terms
they are simple right view they are a
column vector times row vector so that's
rank one even if you take two sum of K
of them they are Co low rank so
basically before we look at a
two-dimensional slice of the force
moment tensor what we get is a matrix
that's almost in suspended and we want
except for these lower rank terms so how
do we get rid of this low rank terms so
a simple way is to just try to project
to some orthogonal subspaces that make
all of them disappear so this s is not
very easy to let me draw a picture so
this s really we have these K the K
different covariance matrices Sigma 1
1 Sigma 2 2 Sigma K what this s is
trying to do is we fix a set of
coordinates H we take all the columns in
each in each of these matrices see this
will give us K times H vectors the
spanner s will be the the subspace s
will be the span of all these K times H
vectors so if we notice span as you know
suspend s and somehow the I and J we
chose as I and J here are all in this
subset s sorry in this subset H then
when we project to the orthogonal
subspace of s so the sky will be of
course in s because it's ice column this
Phi is the trace column and by
definition it should also be in the span
s so so when we project to the
orthogonal subspace all these terms
should disappear and what we really have
is just the projection of the first term
so basically we can just take this
projection as it's a span of columns of
course matrices and we will choose the H
two half-sites root n so the rank or
dimension or whatever of s is K times
root n which by our assumptions this is
much smaller and so in particular we can
hope this to be a space of dimension K
times root and instead of span the
entire subspace
so so once we do this projection for any
IJ that's in this set each we will get
one matrix that is that has none of
these terms and it's really in the span
of the current matrices but after it's a
projection
how many such matrices can we get we can
get for any IJ we can get one matrix IJ
has to be in H so we have n choices but
the dimension of the span of the current
matrices is only K so we have n vectors
in RK dimensional space so in the good
case we can hope all these n or n
matrices of these n matrices spans the
entire K dimensional space and again we
need to use a smooth novices to say that
this is indeed true so basically once we
take I'd this slices and take this
projection for different IJ we get span
of the cornice matrices in this
particular subspace s perp
okay so so basically we know how to go
from here to here there are two problems
left we can we need to know how to get
the span of the columns in the
covariance matrices as a space s we also
need to go from this projection of the
span of the covariance matrix to the
span of the Goron's matrix let's focus
on the first problem first so the
problem now is how do we find the span
of columns of covariance matrices the
idea is very similar so recall as is
suspended 3d the span of these columns
we again look at the moment structure
but here instead we look at one
dimensional slices again please believe
me that if you do the calculations this
is what you get and the key observation
here is this is so I three columns
columns this is I ones column if all
these indices I 1 I 2 I 3 are in this
set H this whole web term must be a
vector in the subspace s that we wanted
now we will just choose all the possible
choices for I 1 I 2 I 3 and the number
of possible choices is roughly n to the
1.5 because we assumed size of H is
square root n so we have n to the 1.5
actors but the dimension of s is K times
root n is even smaller and it's
definitely much smaller than n to the
one point five again we can hope all
these entries of 1.5 vectors to span the
entire subspace s and in order to show
that we need to show that these
coefficients are not to generate but
what are these coefficients what these
coefficients are just increase in the
currents matrix which by assumptions
they are randomly perturb so it's very
likely that the coefficients are not
degenerate the proof again depends
heavily on this smooth analysis setting
so that's how we get to spend as so
finally are there's only one step left
so we know how to get the span of course
matrices but in some subspace we really
want to spend off the entire currents
matrix so how do we recover the span of
the currents matrix from its projections
okay if I have just one projection this
is this seems very hard right I have
four projections the information is lost
I have I have no way to do that but we I
can repeat the previous procedure on two
different subsets I say h1 and maybe h2
and if I do this on two different
subsets of columns I will get the
projection into two different subspaces
it turns out that s1 and s2 there will
be two subspaces that are destroyed
there are no vectors that are in both of
the subspace
except of course true or zero vector so
we'll repeat on two sets and basically
what we got
that's not exactly that but if you can
think of it this way so we we get two we
want to spend off this whole currents
matrix in the first projection maybe we
don't see all these entries in the
second projection we don't see it's easy
injuries but we still want we want to
merge these two projections to form the
entire matrix well of course if it's
just one matrix this is very simple
right I can just use these coordinates
and merge them and I get this matrix it
slightly harder because I have a linear
span of the matrices the inner subspace
of matrices can can be represented using
many different bases and they are
equivalent only up to a linear
transformation so it's perfectly
possible that the linear transformation
that I used in this span is different
from that linear transformations that
are used in this part is aspiration
but uh but notice that I still have many
of the common interests so I can hope to
align these two linear basis by aligning
them in these common base common
coordinates once they agree in the
common coordinates I can just directly
read all these entries and get the
smirched space so all this is really
just basic linear algebra so so here's
the algorithm at least at the end so
basically we know using moment
structures we can first find the span of
columns over there and if we project is
also know subspace of that we can use
the 2d slices to get the span of the
Curren matrix matrices in this subspace
we get this for two different subspaces
and then we merge the result to get the
span of the karez matrix now we have to
span off the course matrix we can reduce
the number of variables and solve
systems of linear equations together
unfolded moments and now once we have
the unfolded moments we can apply it's a
tensor decomposition algorithm as in the
previous talk to get the solution so in
the rest maybe five minutes ayah that I
have let me show you just a very simple
lemma in the papers that gives you a
flavor of what we need to show for the
smooth knowledge setting to work so
recall we have this definition of s we
want to say for example this s should
have rank or dimension exactly K times H
this is quite important in our algorithm
and we want this to happen robustly this
ranked a times H but inst if I collect
all these columns and form a matrix it
should be of truth half large smallest
singular value so that is very important
improving the sample complexity pawns so
how do we prove that
well we collect all these columns to
form this matrix by its most analysis
framework this is equal to some Archon
or worst case instance plus a
perturbation it's aperture all these
matrices they have some structure as
they are these columns from the currents
matrices so they have some symmetric
structure so basically this part is the
same as this part right this is true for
both the our channel it's a true
parameters and the perturbation we don't
want this kind of correlations in the
perturbation because we want it to be as
random as possible so we will do it this
we just simply ignore all these
interests that have correlations now we
have less number of rows since we looked
at our sub matrix we know the smallest
singular value here it can only decrease
so as long as I can show the smallest
singular value here is good I am okay
then I want to get rid of this original
because this worst case I have no
control over that I just project to the
orthogonal subspace of the column span
and because I just looked at projection
the smallest singular value can only
decrease so so as long as I can show the
sky is good I'm okay but after this
projection the original disappears so
the projection is really equal to the
projection of a random matrix the sky's
a random caution matrix the projection
of our random daschle matrix is another
random caution matrix so this is a
random rectangular Gaussian matrix and
whose singular values we understand very
well and for example ludos and then
we're shining gives a very nice result
that gives very tight bonds
on the singular values of rectangular
matrices and we can just use that and
that's just as if she tries to give you
a flavor of the proofs that we need to
do in this analysis framework so in
conclusion we show that learning mixture
of gaussians is easy in high dimensions
when number of the missions is much
larger than K square even lower order
moments up to six can provide lots of
information and we can actually hope to
utilize this information by carefully
looking at the structure of the moment
matrix moment tensors
there are many open problems so the most
interesting one we is can we relax this
we need a dimension to be larger than
100 K square can we probably use some
higher moments to reduce this maybe a or
K to the epsilon also our algorithm only
works in the smooth analysis setting it
would be nice to have exclusive
condition for the covariance matrices
like in the previous case we can say if
the means are linearly independent the
algorithm works here we don't know how
to say anything like that and finally
this is a new way of decomposing this
tensor that's formed by it's a PSD
Korres matrices maybe it has some other
applications sense
any questions pearl yes in the
projection case and now you have many
projections are using all of them or
just you take the right number and you
seem that this is it
oh sorry well you can you start with a
subspace when you say I know the
projection once ups on and smaller
subspace right yes so then you want to
reconstruct the subspace yes because
which I want I using all of them for
reconstruction or only part which sort
of the right number and the this is yes
so it's only in our case we are lucky
because our projections they are like
say have more than half of the
dimensions so we can just take two of
them and that that's good enough for us
and you convince enough you hope that
you don't contradict the other
projections it gets this so are these
the typography statements that there is
the variant already the inverse
polynomial of the feather of probability
is e to the end his absalom it was a
minus n to the epsilon or some constant
epsilon
or any local 1000 yes so no there's no
lower banda what there's a lower bound
on Kayne and because if the pay is to
smaller than our of these block things
maybe you don't have enough of them
I didn't state that because when K is
small you can use more char and valence
algorithm and that algorithm when K is a
constant for us in polynomial time and
has to be at least 100 K square for the
yes oh oh you means a lower bound for a
force a problem no we don't know any
lower bound for the problem I there
shows that n could be as small as K to
the epsilon at least yeah
yeah in the beginning at your cram
problem so you were saying that that if
you only do one measurement then you
need an exponential number of of crabs
it's in the interest case so so let's
say in this worst case but notes often
arrive in the generic case in the
general case I don't know but I [ __ ]
well in papers they give this counter
example of this lower bound examples
that says the are two mixer ourself
captions that have very different
parameters but they are very close in
distribution so in particular you cannot
hope to distinguish them unless you have
exponential in K that is what I mean
look what's the vision of the Kaveri
yes it's a lot of things for example all
these columns they should be a
non-degenerate and covariance matrices
themselves should also be announced it's
just different sub matrices of that
should be in bounty generate I don't not
that I know of and also because these
conditions I can choose a random subset
and so if these subsets doesn't work
maybe I can choose a different subset so
I don't know what is the strongest can
do like the brick is condition we can
work this other question
all right let's tie home again